karneval ist luca und meine lieben
freunde hier sehe ich schon hier an der
brille und irene schon allein im xsight
mit herzlich willkommen ja heute zum
mittlerweile schon fünften folge fahren
wie es bei jedem video der reihe mobile
monday ist mit luca der fall ist ist
auch das heutige video
selbstverständlich wieder freundlich
unterstützt worden von google plate denn
im rahmen der playon kampagne spiele ich
verschiedene mobile games auf meinem
google pixel mio
wir legen natürlich direkt los mit agrio
und meine damen und herren zuallererst
müssen wir uns einen namen aussuchen und
ich würde sagen ich nenne mich luki bei
4.000 keiner will mit loki bei 4.000 ihr
seht ihr auch schon den luki bei 4.000
unterwegs auf der suche nach kleineren
zählen die ihr essen kann und da geht es
jetzt nämlich auch schon direkt darum um
was es bei ergo geht hier sollte jeder
kennen oder olegario habe ich früher sei
sie häufig auf meinem kanal hochgeladen
also wirklich irgendwie alle vier fünf
tage ich hab da auch irgendwie 10 12
videos zu gemacht auf meinem kanal ist
geht auf jeden fall darum dass wir diese
person da sind luki bei 4.000 der
absolute beste zerstörer im ganzen
gameboys und wir müssen kleinere zellen
essen also ihr seht schon kleinere
zellen hier wenn ich über die
drüberfahren dann verschwinden die das
heißt einfach weil ich die sm hier links
kann ich ohne gott da kommt bulgarien
oben ein gott
achtung kacke
lugano mein gott okay jetzt kommt
ägypten und italien heute mit frau
italien
ich habe mich gerade schon gesplittet
und italien rom
sehr lecker schön italien schönen
italien hier pizza pasta ich muss auf
jeden fall kleinere zellen essen und da
geht es nicht um diese ganz kleinen
sondern auch um solche wie
beispielsweise hier kanada ich war mal
in kanada kanada
ich habe mich jetzt gerade ein bisschen
zu häufig gesplittet das heißt ich bin
jetzt hier ganz oft vorhanden ihren gott
da kann ich essen
der irak online online das heißt mein
größerer muss den online jungs werdet
mal wieder ein cabrio geht's auf jeden
fall darum und das seht ihr hier schon
dass man die kleineren zählen auffrisst
und dadurch wird man selbst eine größere
zelle und je größer man ist desto weiter
oben ist man im leaderboard und je
größer man ist desto größere zellen kann
man noch essen
das ist das ganze spielprinzip wo mich
das war ganz kurz zu erklären ich habe
früher auf jeden fall so häufig agraria
hallo
okay da seht ihr schon was passiert wenn
man gleich groß und zwar fährt man dann
quasi einfach übereinander drüber der
mars fällt aber auch ein bisschen
zickzack schwingen
ich hasse das spiel jetzt schon wieder
ich weiß noch früher meine videos cario
er da war ich richtig stolz als ich
einmal den platz eins erreicht hat und
danach habe ich in jedem weiteren video
eigentlich platz eins erreicht also das
war dann auch nichts so besonderes auf
jeden fall gehalten spiel was man
einerseits wirklich auf dem handy
spielen kann also beispielsweise auf dem
google pixel und man kann sich das in
place herunterladen beispielsweise auch
über eine info karten oben oder da ich
weiß nicht irgendwo hier ist auf jeden
fall gerade eine infokarte und darüber
könnt ihr euch das spiel engagiert place
herunterladen können er war drauf klickt
oder könnt ihr euch das download und
dann könnt ihr mir immer gerne euren
score und in die kommentare schreiben
allerdings ist das tolle an addario halt
auch das ist auf seiner website zu
spielen und zwar auf der website ag.de
und da ist bulgarien und dem versuch
jetzt mal zu essen
damit sind gleich groß auf jeden fall
ist es halt ein voll simples spiel aber
total süchtig machen darum ist germany
und schon wenig zweck ich glaube jeder
hat meine zeit in seinem leben wo er
unfassbar süchtig nach agrio waren ist
die ganze zeit gespielt hat man kann
zwischendurch einfach mal auf mein handy
spiel ist verbraucht nicht viel speicher
und so weiter und so fort aber ich bin
hier natürlich nicht dazu da um agrio in
ein zu kriechen
ich will ja wirklich was reißen deswegen
schauen wir mal da oben hier ist angela
merkel also ich bin dabei die angela
haben ein heutiges ziel ist es angela
merkel zu essen hier links ist germany
dass angela merkel angela das kann doch
nicht sein wieso das das ist auch so ein
ding
die kleineren zellen sind schneller als
die größeren danke ja wir sind ja alle
ziemlich gleich groß jetzt wird aber in
tortuga 4000
doch noch nie war ein ganz okay ihr seht
schon wer der größte bei dem ganzen geld
drin ist und zwar ist luca beute 1000m
hier unten links ist der jordan ok
billardkugel es vielleicht noch ein
stückchen größer als lucchini 4000 und
der cuba an meiner hand
so schnell kann es gehen meine lieben
freunde
allerdings ist ja das tolle an agrio
dass wir direkt wieder in eine neue
runde rein starten können wir können
hier wieder ein bisschen rum fahren und
so weiter und so fort er mich wollte das
heutige video auf jeden fall mal so ein
bisschen nutzen um auch so ein bisschen
den nostalgie zu erzwingen
ganz kurz hier ist übrigens wartet da
hier ist die welt zu ende
und irgendwo hier links ja genau also
hier ist quasi die wand also es ist
jetzt nicht unendlich groß die map hier
deswegen kann man jetzt beispielsweise
wenn man total riesig ist jetzt auch
nicht irgendwie abbauen und in eine
andere richtung oder irgendwie hat
sondern es ist wirklich begrenzt
allerdings wie gerade bereits gesagt
wollte ich das heutige video auch von
ein bisschen nutzen um im osten
[Musik]
ich wollte im heutigen video so ein
bisschen in nostalgie schweben und so
ein bisschen darüber lagern war zu
früher auf meinem kanal war uns weiter
und so fort
weil früher hatte ich ja wirklich
eigentlich nur drei serien auf einem
kanal oder 4
und zwar um ein gott der unter mir hey
hey wie fett ist ja ich habe früher auf
einem kanal halten
wollte magath wirklich seit monaten mit
zehn jahren nicht mehr gespielt
weder auf einem kanal noch wirklich
einfach so aber das spiel ist eigentlich
echt ziemlich nahe
die sache ist was ich gerade sagen
wollte ich hatte ja früher auf meinem
kanal wirklich nur so 34 verschiedene
serien und das war clever botta dario
akinator gott sie me later und minecraft
und das waren jetzt fünf serien nicht
und ihr müsst eigentlich alle irgendwie
die ich dabei haben beim spielen oder
was das war auf jeden fall die zeit auf
einem kanal so rund um das jahr 2015
2016 rum und das war ich als lustig weil
ich jeden tag eigentlich genau wusste
was sie hochladen irgendwie wird's für
mich auf dauer langweilig weil ich
einfach gemerkt hab gar nicht erst
da hat sich einer übel gesplittet alter
acht gibt acht die team in ok das
passiert auch relativ häufig dass man
mit einem kumpel diddy zusammen in der
lobby geht und dann gibt man sich
gegenseitig irgendwie zellen ab und soll
auf jeden fall war es früher halt so
dass ich mega bock hatte auf die ganzen
serien dadurch dass sich allerdings nur
diese vier fünf serien hatte auf meinem
kanal wird auf dauer ein bisschen
langweilig und über monate hinweg habe
ich dann immer mehr unterschiedliche
sachen hochgeladen und auch jetzt gerade
ist mein kanal halt wirklich eher so
dass ich jeden tag etwas anderes
hochladen und das feiere ich habe
allerdings letztes halt wirklich
kommentare gelesen und dass es mit auch
einer der gründe warum ich mit google
play gesagt habe mega lustig wenn ich
eigentlich mal so eine gaming serie
wieder machen würde weil ich einfach so
viele kommentare gelesen habe er luca
ladner bitte wieder mehr gaming hoch und
da könnt ihr mir gern mal schreiben ob
er weiterhin bonn
was sie nicht unterkriegen von den
eltern luca da würd mich eure meinung
wirklich mal unfassbar dollar den
kommentaren interessieren
und zwar einerseits ob ihr wirklich
schon abonnent seit seit damals das
sowieso was für mich das geht mir gerade
ab die teils mein gott die teilen sich
irgendwie alter was ist hier gerade los
pushen gegeben ganz kurz was
geschieht hier gerade irgendwie schießen
die gerade so teile raus
das kann man hier beispielsweise machen
da kann man hier schießen da gebe ich
hier einen ab und auch ergibt bei zurück
danke schön oh danke der dankeschön mit
mir kannste nicht team hier sonst
kriegst 1 zurück und kriegen auch einen
dahin habe ich hier ein paar abgekommen
geht man auf jeden fall würde mich eure
meinung in den kommentaren wirklich mal
interessieren
hättet ihr bock dass ich mehr wieder so
games hochladen wie beispielsweise
addario clever bord akinator das waren
ja sehr simple games so die man auf
webseiten gespielt hat und so weiter und
so fort oder hättet ihr wirklich er
wieder bock drauf
luke relativ cool würde mich echt
weniger interessieren weil ich glaube
das habe ich letztens auch schon mal ein
video vom betragen vor ein paar tagen
gefragt
das ding ist nämlich dass mein kanal
natürlich irgendwie ich will das
hochladen was ich feiere
aber auf der anderen seite will ich auch
natürlich das machen worauf ihr bock
habt und ja der könnte mich essen ich
mache allerdings mal den ja das war
nicht gut das war nicht so schlau
das war nicht schlau
das war ich bin jedem moment glaube ich
ein paar sekunden später
wir machen noch eine letzte runde
[Musik]
andere stelle ich das heute wieder jetzt
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde die wie bereits gesagt bock auf
addario habt dann schaut gerne einfach
unten in die video beschreibung dann
findet nämlich einen link und dann könnt
ihr euch dort agrarium google places
runterladen schreibt mir auch wie
bereits gesagt gern und in die
kommentare welchen score ihr dort habt
ich war zwischendurch auf jeden fall
mega gut schreibt mir zudem auch mal
gerne die kommentare ob wir weiterhin
bock auf mobile games auf einem kanal ab
beziehungsweise nicht nur bauwerke
sondern vielleicht auch in welcher
anderen gamer wird mich eure meinung auf
jeden fall mehr gern frisst hirn worauf
er bock hat was ich mal wieder hochladen
soll
und ansonsten würde ich sagen seht ihr
schon sind wir jetzt in der endart
angekommen hier findet ihr noch mal das
cabrio logo ihr könnt ihr draufklicken
euch das spiel wie bereits gesagt
herunterladen virenscan und in die
kommentare schreiben und hier ist auch
das letzte google play game on mobile
man ist mit luca video verlinken durch
auch gerne anschauen das aus der letzten
woche mit sandra und ansonsten